the world is going right okay that's for
sure MH and it's just the beginning oh
it's just the beginning it's not the end
and worse to come sorry there is more to
come yes of course what happened in
Italy in last
September uh is going to happen uh in
Spain very soon uh in Germany very soon
probably in France in in swen already
happened in States yeah in the states
and so on so uh is this is this the
coming back of
fascism uh no I don't think so if we
look at fascist fascism sorry as an
historical uh formation but is it the
coming back of
musini I would say yes it is uh in which
way way in the way that musolini uh has
been not only the founder of fascist
movement and party and dictatorship but
even the first uh populist leader of
modern times the point is that every
time that history drives uh to a crisis
like musolini understood very well
people want goes to the um the the the
strong colors used to say the the banner
well with with a strong color red or
black okay and and we are at the same uh
moment of history as 100 years ago we
are in a crisis we are in a crisis for
many reasons no and now people don't
listen to the sophisticate uh argument
of liberal and Democrats and they still
want primary colors red or or or black
they prefer a a a rhetoric of fear to a
rhetoric of hope it's last thing I want
to say
that makes musolini the father of every
populist leader nowadays musolini came
from Socialist Party okay he was a very
beloved leader of the Socialist Party
the Socialist Party was the party of
hope not the great 19th centuries idea
that the life of our son and daughters
would be better than our
and so on hope the Rising Sun musolini
was kicked out of the Socialist Party
and
um after the world war he he understands
one simple things terrifying things that
there is only one political passion
Stronger Than Hope and that is fear so
he bets everything on fear on fear of
what fear of others people hopes and so
that that's that's the drill okay one
problem not many problems we don't need
a parliament you know that represent the
complexity of society and of our
problems there is only one problem that
problem is an enemy and that enemy is a
foreigner you know and Foreigner used to
be socialist at the time and immigrants
nowadays if you see all the populist
leader of course when when they size
power they do many things but when they
campaign okay they campaign on one thing
immigration enemy fear
Invasion yeah but there's another
important way briefly to say what you
just said which is that the modern
period is not as different as the
premodern period as we think it is in
other words you look at these elements
that come into play in the war on
liberalism and the Resurgence of
fascistic things and what do you see you
see the fear of difference you see the
fear of the other you see resentment of
the privileged
you see the love of power you see this
um archaic sense of the group in other
words it's very important and this goes
to what you said before yes um there was
a rupture in the modern period and
everything was there was the
Enlightenment and so on but you know at
Virginia wolf wrote once that human
nature changed on February 21st 1910
it's one of the stupidest sentences that
anybody ever wrote and human nature did
not change
and one of the things that you see in
the Resurgence of fascism it's a kind of
adism it's a return to fundamental
qualities if you want to say of the
human heart or of human life together
with other human beings that no amount
of rationality and technology and
Industry is ever going to erase fism is
a modern phenomenon I think that I think
it builds on atavistic uh trends of
Human Condition such as a friend enemy
distinction and the fear of of
difference but at the same time fascism
it's a modern phenomenon because this is
another phase of democracy it's another
possibility the darker possibility of
democracy and is the possibility of
homogeneity of being afraid of
Singularity being afraid of
individualism and that's why uh fascism
it's uh a 20th and 21st century
phenomenon that's why there are so many
historical analogies between the 1920s
and 1930s and the present because we are
in a democratic era and so democracy can
take those two faces and I think when in
the middle we're right now in the middle
of a of a battle between two
interpretation of of democracy whether
democracy is about popular sovereignty
and all the implications that has in
terms of homogeneity and also called of
a leader uh or if democracy is about
pluralism and individuality and
Institution and distinctions and
separation of powers but in a way
historically both are consequences of
democracy nationalism nationalism
without its ugly problems it's a
consequence of democracy of the idea
that The Sovereign people it's Sovereign
so it has to have a certain identity and
in order to have a certain identity he
has to share certain common cultural
features imagined or real or artificial
and so much of the horrors we have seen
in the 20th century in terms of total
arianism in terms of fascism in terms of
Communism are also consequences of
modernity and and democracy and popular
sovereignty